hey youtubers it's Charlie this week I
asked you to submit all of your arrow
and flash related questions so much
happened we got to meet the daughter of
Ra's al Ghul and we got to learn all
about the cast of the flash show Grant
Gustin even trolled us with a picture of
himself wearing the flash costume no
joke this is the actual picture that he
posted I ended up picking five arrow
questions and five flash questions with
one bonus question about a bunch of
spin-offs if you're finding me for the
first time I do Q&A episodes each time
new episodes there be sure to subscribe
to get everything
even though there isn't a new episode
next week I'll still think of something
fun to do so don't worry so QA time
let's get going question number one 7th
element asks do you think that Oliver
could ever take Deathstroke alone
considering the mirakuru
if anyone stronger than Deathstroke
reveals themselves how will Oliver stand
up to them that's a bit of a two-part
question no Oliver could not beat him in
a fair fight he could beat him by
fighting dirty because of the mirakuru
Slade has almost limitless stamina so
all he'd have to do is just fight Oliver
to stalemate until Oliver became
exhausted and couldn't fight anymore
to answer the other part of your
question that's why they don't have
crazy super-powered people on air all
the times it would just get ridiculous
typically you know from a narrative
standpoint it's much easier to
conceptualize human versus human and
superhuman versus superhuman that's why
on the flash show you'll probably see
some more crazy super-powered people
because the Speed Force is a superpower
so obviously the villain has to have
superpowers too question number two a
leash patel asks as flash and arrow
exists in the same universe what does it
mean for eras villains will we be seeing
supervillains with actual superpowers
and if so which ones do you reckon will
appear on arrow like I just said no
there probably won't be a lot of
super-powered villains on arrow it'll be
slightly more realistic villains like
Slade you know enhanced humans but not
super humans question number three
Callum Butler asks I know this program
is normally on at 9:00 on sky1 when does
it return in the UK so the most recent
listing I saw for Sky HD was February
20th that's episode 10 so I would just
assume that each episode for the rest of
the season will air week to week after
that question number four almond crisps
tasks we saw a sex scene in the end
between Ollie and Sara what do you
expect from their relationship so a lot
of you guys have been asking about the
ships on the show you know illicit Ebola
City and Oliver and Sara now I don't
think it's gonna last
typically heroes in the comic
books don't always get happy endings or
the happy endings you think that they're
gonna get it's a lot more fun to watch a
hero rise to the occasion you know rise
up and in order to do that you have to
be struck low by a villain so I think
something is gonna happen to break the
canary and Oliver up by the end of the
season I have no idea what that's going
to be but I am expecting it question
number five sonny tyler asks birds of
prey so is the hunters coming back and
what about the oracle so i actually have
a lot of birds of prey news careful for
potential spoilers because it kind of
involves some of the things that are
coming after this birds of prey episode
so if you don't wanna know anything just
turn the volume down for just a second
so birds of prey is episode 17 that
comes right after the Suicide Squad
episode Huntress is coming back her
character's a little bit different in
this season if you remember at the end
of season 1 whenever she left
Oliver was trying to get her to stop
killing people and going all nutters all
over the city
she's only gotten worse so the story is
gonna be heard coming back seeking
vengeance
Laurel gets in the middle of that Sara
jumps in to save Laurel and almost tries
to kill Helena so whenever the birds of
prey start they're actually gonna start
at each other's throats
literally the creator said during a
recent interview though they're taking a
multi season art approach with their
story that implies that we're gonna get
birds of prey in season 3 meaning that
caity lotz will be the canary in season
3 I know a lot of people have been
wondering whether or not she's gonna die
this season and Laurel is gonna become
the canary that kind of implies with
this birds of prey talked that she's not
as a side note though in that same
interview they talked about the
Deathstroke character in the same way
you know this multi season arc also
implying that Slade will be back next
season
okay so here's where we start on the
flash questions number 6
Shelby Larson asks my friend wants to
watch the flash but not arrow and then
in quotations you have I don't know why
do you think it would be possible to
only watch the flash or only watch arrow
do you need to see both to understand
what's going on your friends are silly
you should tell them to drink the
kool-aid and watch arrow too but know
they don't have to worry about that the
show will be designed so that anybody
can just jump on during season 1 and
understand what's going on they won't
have to have read the comic books or
watched arrow or even know anything
about the characters question number 7
Mitchell Nights asks what will the flash
suit look like short answer like the new
52 version there might be a few things
they alter just a little bit but Geoff
Johns said that they are sticking very
close to that red suit in the comic
books the real big question to ask
though is how the suit is
to work in execution is it going to be
like Oliver's arrow suit is he gonna
have to like literally put the pants on
you know like crawl into that fabric I'm
guessing that the vibe character at STAR
Labs is going to be his friend and he'll
help him design a suit that will work at
SuperSpeed question number 8 Ralph C
asks about the race spending for the
West characters impossible wally west
character what do you think no I don't
care about that kind of stuff and I
don't think it matters if they find an
actor that's perfect for rold they will
change character sometimes just to make
it work as for a while in West they
haven't cast that character yet but
given that they're sticking pretty close
to the comic books I think it's fair to
say that he'll show up on the show
eventually question number nine hero
Danny Phantom asks do you think that
Barry will have his own team like
Oliver's team on arrow it'll be a lot
like arrow during season one you
remember Oliver basically was the
vigilante on his own for a little while
then eventually he told Diggle and then
eventually Felicity after that so Grant
Gustin will slowly build his team
obviously I'm expecting detective West
and iris West to be on that team and
eventually the vibe character - question
number ten summer Bradshaw asks several
questions I mash them all up into one
how Jordan Green Lantern meet up other
Geoff Johns characters and whatnot like
Gorilla Grodd and rogues gallery so you
had a ton of great questions so I tried
to match my answer up into one big thing
no there won't be any green Lancer just
because this is a flash show so
obviously they have to establish that
character first before a Green Lantern
can exist in it but given that Geoff
Johns is heavily involved in the
creative look for Easter eggs in the
background there will definitely be a
lot of fun stuff that they'll slip in as
for the villains gorilla grodd really
feels like a big season to type villain
as for the rest of season one I am
expecting other people from the rogues
gallery to show up you know Captain Cold
he's obviously a major flash villain he
has to come at some point just for
reference so danielle Panabaker will
probably be the first super villain that
he actually fights it just depends on
when she gets her powers either she
hasn't at the beginning of the show or
she gets him in the first couple of
episodes I'm expecting Rick Kuznets
professor zoom character to hide in the
shadows for most of the season though
this week's bonus question also comes
from summer she asked about spin-off
shows a lot have you been asking about
spin-offs so there's Young Justice and
Suicide Squad right now the only thing
that's really seriously been discussed
is Suicide Squad because some of those
characters had been on air already Young
Justice would require several other
characters to show up first it really
just depends on how well the flash does
and if arrow continues to get
picked up thanks so much for so many
questions guys this was a lot of fun as
always remember arrows gonna be off the
air for about three weeks so I will do
something fun next week be sure to
subscribe to get whatever it's gonna be
and don't forget Walking Dead is back to
this Sunday there's also a special Game
of Thrones video that I'm going to be
doing they're doing some special behind
the scenes stuff so big stuff coming on
Sunday right now click here to learn all
about the new flash show I just did my
first preview and click here to get my
most recent arrow video thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives